I was age 15 when I march across the
bridge we saw two state troopers with
their billy clubs or anything and I
couldn't see I was running out
and they are watching television that's
it oh my god I jumped out to be and I
was only a five minutes away and I
remember some of my classmates saying to
me you know what we may get hurt you
know we already heard it no one
anticipated that law enforcement people
would be as brutal as they were I was
working at Good Samaritan Hospital I was
employed in the business office some
people came in cabs cars walking but the
numbers just kept growing I was scared
we know what was gonna happen as we went
along where they're gonna be people that
will be shooting at you
but also determine that I needed to be a
part of making a difference means
determination determination
determination determination we would
just always determine to have our power
rights and if you notice most of the
masses that you see in the protests were
those of students college students high
school students etc because we had
nothing to lose when I look back at 17
it seems very young now but 26 was also
young Martin Luther King was only 26 so
these were still very young people that
made these
happen and at the age of 12 I made the
choice to join the marchers to march to
the capital of Montgomery well I think
my mother she knew my free spirit and
she cautioned me to be careful I don't
know I don't think she could have
stopped me at that time and I could see
justice to me as a child it looked like
a sea of people moving in unison and I
could feel something within me then that
elevated my excitement to me going
tonight rather one of the high points of
my life I feel so good I see that many
people and at this reception
and he came by by 2 or 3 which boy went
enough for Tennessee that's the last
time I saw
I'm glad to be here better tell my chair
and my grandkids then I was wondering
soldier and I will torture and I think
in ways that I don't understand yet it
helped me to be the person that I am
whenever I cross the Edmund Pettus
Bridge going to Selma it's just a chill
that arms over you to think that this is
where it was my mom had tried for years
to vote and knew the answers and she was
not allowed
you've gone to what I had gone through
you had no fear